whilst Americans may eat turkey
basically just lots of pie everything in
in pie lopa jelly beans and jelly with
the mashed potatoes and anything that's
left in the fridge I think is the idea
well I get mixed up between the Civil
War and Thanksgiving which is not very
good science to Abraham Lincoln I think
it's a de celebration of when the
settlers came over they came over they
weren't very good at it to begin with
and like there's a route they got bailed
out by the native population and then
when they finally managed to not be
rubbish as it they went they go us who
might know better you do anything I mean
they cook they having a large meal I
think any evening and I feel it there's
a Thanksgiving Parade I feel like it's
quite drunk time on Gossip Girl
Serina gets very drunk on Thanksgiving
the president either like pardons a
turkey or they ritually slaughter
exactly it's one or the other
both they have a big meal and argue and
then watch and cheer on large men from
rival cities trying to hurt each other
why don't they watch football that I
think Americans watch the bull
Thanksgiving because they are physically
incapable of that point of doing
anything other than seeing from the TV
well then that's does rugby they
analysis or sedated just enough so that
the the natural rage that comes with
watching football won't actually spill
over into to mass violence
[Music]